my body's aging extremely slowly I have
50 biomarkers the things you would
normally expect like cholesterol and
triglycerides and things like that that
are in the perfect optimal clinical
outfit range I have 100 biomarkers that
are less than my chronological age
several Fitness tests where I test out
as an elite 18 year old my body runs
three degrees Fahrenheit cooler than
normal so no matter how you're looking
at it whether it's my DNA methylation my
fitness test my biomarkers my phenotypic
markers whatever you're looking at the
data says the same thing I'm in near
perfect health
Brian Johnson welcome to the show
thank you for having me
do you fear death
no I love life
is there a distinction between those two
I
I do not have a I I know what fear feels
like and I don't experience that emotion
when contemplating death I
spend a good bit of time looking at the
longevity uh subreddit many many years
ago when David Sinclair first came on
the scene and um one of the things that
I kind of realized or I thought I might
have realized was it seemed like a
little bit of a rehabilitated denial of
death in a way uh it seems like there
are certain elements of the longevity
community that that do see that but
based on what I've looked at from what
you're doing
it seems like a very enjoyable fun
experiment where you're trying to see
how far you can push your body but I'm
trying to work out you know is there
deeper down in the recesses is there
something is there a denial of death is
there a fear from from what's coming in
the future driving you at all
my my main source of inspiration is
having read hundreds of biographies
I love learning about people in their
time and place that we're able to work
on impossibly hard things so Talent is
the ability to hit the target no one
else can genius hits the target no one
else can see
and the majority of us in life
we play the games that Society gives us
so that's hitting the target So
currently you know social media
followers and you know this and that so
people like to play games where points
can be kept and you can be compared to
people and ranked
uh genius is a different game it's
trying to find things that don't exist
and you need to have the stamina and
fortitude to go out and pave your own
path and do things that are not
recognized appreciated or valued even in
your lifetime
and so to me that reading biographies is
about people who do that is they really
try to survey all of existence they are
somehow
immune to their time and place
and are able to see these things that's
really so in my
in my understanding of My reality I seek
to be like those people
and with that it means disregarding
current wisdom around approaches for
Health Fitness sleep diet nutrition
training everything
everything the reason why we exist what
we do with our existence
everything okay so in your view what is
the reason why we exist
lucky us we exist I mean I do not recall
asking to exist
it just happened
and I really enjoy existing and I would
like to continue to exist
and these questions for example like
what is the meaning of life I think that
is
an example of what it means to exist I
don't think there is an answer it just
is a person's answer is reflective of
that of the time and place like you
basically it's a mirror of the social
and cultural norms and the person's
trying to express themselves within
those Norm structures and again trying
to hit targets uh but to me it's we live
at this really special time uh no
no uh
human before us no generation before us
has ever been in the situation we're in
where we're on this of potentially
radically extending and altering what it
means to be uh conscious being and it's
just it's delicious Beyond uh words and
I think the faster we can fully Embrace
this opportunity the better off we are
but I think we're we're still a little
bit zombified like we just haven't quite
seen it and
um
we'll be better off if we can try to
catch these these waves I like the idea
of the meaning of life being basically
dependent on the local ecology in the
local time so if it was uh Britain in
1100 A.D it would be in service of God
you know it would be hoeing the garden
and the sun beating down on your back
but you're doing it because you need to
praise the Lord and if it's you know
pick your time pick whatever it is that
people desire
I mean just just building on your
comment like if you basically look
throughout thousands of years of human
history and if you look at the emergent
spiritual practices and religions that
have emerged and you put a Chinese you
know you put a wall in between
the technology that time and place and
the ideologies that are merged so just
not even including the personalities who
gave birth to these ideologies
they're simply a reflection of what was
technologically capable in that time and
place
that's it uh you know human Guru
narrative aside that's just it it's just
a mirror on what on the Practical extent
to which humans can Aspire okay so in
this regard does technology unlock our
ability to think about our meaning and
our place in the world
yeah I mean the
behind blueprint I mean a lot of people
observe the blueprint they think that
blueprint is about health and wellness
and anti-aging
it is really a contemplation about the
future of our existence
and
what I think we've demonstrated is that
we've built an algorithm that takes
better care of me than I can
and we know what happens when algorithms
get better at us at doing things flying
airplanes
calculators
digital navigation You Name It We
embrace them because they do a given
thing better and they help us achieve
our goals better than we could ourselves
so we can free our minds up and do other
things
with blueprint
I think I've I'm showing
uh
following Nietzsche of God is dead I
think the mind is dead
that if if the algorithmic ability if I
can measure you know the 35 trillion
cells in my body an algorithm can better
manage entropy than I can
of course I'm going to opt into it and
free myself up to do other things
and I think that's what we're at as a
society I mean uh so yes does unlock
does technology unlock it yes I mean I
think at the most fundamental level and
the most meaningful
philosophical
uh
Revolution to happen in a long time the
mind is dead it's here like it just
arrived
I think a lot of
speculation about artificial
intelligence maybe five years to ten
years ago was that yeah sure we'll be
able to automate certain things it'll be
able to do kind of normal
forward-thinking processes but it can't
do creativity you can't do art it can't
do writing it can't do
music and then it turns out that it
probably can and given enough time it's
going to be able to do it better than us
one of the interesting things to reflect
on from your point there was that um a
navigation system everybody uses Google
Maps or Apple Maps or some equivalent
now right
why we used to navigate by our favorite
roads we would look at a map and have an
A to Z out and go through all of the
different routes and there would be a
co-pilot that would be giving you the
wrong directions
why is it that we were so quickly
prepared to switch from this personal
orienteering approach to using a GPS
well it's because no one was
existentially connected to their ability
to do wayfinding I think that there is a
a difference in kind in terms of how
people see their own regulation of their
physiology right that there is some
sacred sense that I shouldn't go in and
Tinker with what Nature has already done
that it is able to regulate itself it
can optimize so on and so forth there's
uh you know even see this around
vaccines as well that the difference
between somebody taking a pill versus
getting an injection there's just there
are certain relatively arbitrary sort of
rules that we place on what feels sacred
what doesn't what we should Tinker with
what doesn't what we're prepared to
relinquish control of and Outsource to a
computer and what we're not and given
that we as we just said we thought that
AI could do certain things and there was
a limit and it seems like that limit has
been pushed through uh it seems quite
timely that you are
um
trying to break through another Frontier
of assumption not creativity but I guess
self-regulation of the body uh also
using technology
very well said
yeah I'll give you yeah you you
absolutely uh synthesize that
beautifully
I'll give you two thought experiments
which I think capture the essence of
this I hold these blueprint brunches at
my house I call them the first supper
and to prepare people I'm I explain to
them I'm going to introduce a few ideas
to you that are most likely going to
break your brain they're going to
basically you're going to experience one
or multiple existential crises in this
two and a half hour dinner
so here's a few thought exercises to get
your brain prepared like I do those
three and then I give them a thought
experiment and I say
let's let's imagine a scenario where an
algorithm is built specifically for you
your personalized algorithm
and it takes better care of your
Wellness than you can yourself but as
far superior physical and mental
spiritual well-being
you can have this algorithm the the
catch is you have to be willing to
accept its recommendations
and follow its protocol
would you be willing to do it and about
a third of the participants say yes like
anything to Free Me From Myself yes
a third say uh sure but I want to change
a few things it's like LOL that's not
the thought experiment and then a third
group gets deeply offended you know just
what you're saying you touch upon
if they can't decide what to eat and
what to drink and when to do it they
don't understand their existence
uh so that's the thing the first thought
experiment the second thought experiment
I layer on top of that is when you and I
if we say how good is technology going
to be in 20 years time
without questioning it you and I are
going to agree it's better now are we
going to say there's Nanobots in our
bloodstream repairing our DNA in real
time or is it AGI whatever our
speculations are it has this dramatic
assumption that's better
if you and I say what are you and I
going to be like in 20 years from now we
don't even question it it's worse we
just don't know how how slow or how fast
the Decay is going to be
but what if uh in the 25th Century
people were talking about what humans in
the early 21st century changed the
fundamentally altered the future of
human existence it was that humans
figured out how to attach themselves to
the speed the compounded rate of
improvement that we see in our
technology today so when you and I go
with that second thought experiment we
say what are you and I going to be like
in 20 years we don't know but better
unquestionably we believe that
it's like the uh human Moore's Law
affiliation
I like to mean I like to meme things
okay so
um we've we've flirted around what it is
that you're doing at the moment what are
the headlines of what you've managed to
achieve with your protocol so far
I think the most compelling data is that
I've using a state-of-the-art DNA
methylation algorithm
I have slowed my speed of Aging by the
equivalent of 31 years my body now
accumulates aging damage at the speed uh
better than the average 10 year old and
better than 88 percent of 18 year olds
which means you know people at 10 years
old are accumulating aging damage uh
most don't realize that just as you get
older you accumulate damage faster and
it compounds
and so my body's aging extremely slowly
number two is I have 50 biomarkers the
the things you would normally expect
like cholesterol and triglycerides and
things like that that are in the perfect
optimal clinical outcome range I have
100 biomarkers that are less than my
chronological age several Fitness tests
where I test out as an elite 18 year old
my body runs three degrees Fahrenheit
cooler than normal so no matter how
you're looking at it whether it's my DNA
methylation my fitness test my
biomarkers my phenotypic markers
whatever you're looking at the data says
the same thing I'm in near perfect
health
pretty impressive pretty useful
what is the projection presuming that
you don't get into a car accident at
some point what is the projection of
your age
your potential longevity
yeah I mean people are a familiar frame
reference would be what is the return of
investment on this company and investors
typically want like a 3X return or a 5x
return or a 10x return will be out of
the park
think about that on lifespan if you can
be around for the future of these
Technologies coming your return on Life
Investment could be 5x 10x 100x 1000x no
one knows you could have a massive
return in life and so the goal is be
around it's worth doing the hard work
right now to dramatically slow your
speed of Aging what I've been trying to
do with blueprint is when people talk
about aging it's always this oh it's
coming and oh it's exciting and wouldn't
it be amazing if but no one had in my
estimation said okay let's take all of
the current scientific evidence let's
put it in one person and let's see where
we're at let's just give it a go let's
see what the data says is the Fountain
of Youth here right now if not how close
how far where are we at and that's what
I've been trying to do is say actually
you know what it's it's pretty
compelling what's available right now
are you familiar with the concept of
longevity escape velocity
I am yeah so it sounds like you're kind
of referring to that basically that the
longer that you stick about the better
the technology will be down the line
which means that it will be able to
extend your life longer and if there is
a point at which the technology is able
to bypass or uh the technology gets
stronger than the rate at which we age
you go okay my point is to stick about
until that and that would be longevity
escape velocity so I've had a ton of
people on the show talking about
longevity health and fitness and it
seems that the conception the
overarching principles aren't
necessarily as universal especially when
we add your approach into the mix what
is the overarching principles that guide
your approach for longevity
[Music]
yeah this is this has been a fun
learning for me you can have four
anti-aging scientists read the same five
papers
and then ask them to design an
anti-aging protocol and you'll get five
different anti-aging protocols
there's just no agreement and there's
not a way of settling the agreement and
that's why I've endeavored to do this is
I do it and then I share my data and yes
there's limitations of it's n of one but
it's better than n of zero
okay
given your markers given what you have
learned
what does the framework look like or
what does the or what are the principles
and the longest levers that you're
looking at it's a process of measuring
extensively I think I'm potentially the
most measured human in all of history
that is taking that data and it's trying
to assess the very best evidence now
that's
that's an art because again you can have
scientists look at the same data and
they come with come up with different
conclusions so it's looking at the
evidence then it's implement the
protocol uh in a subject like myself
where I'm trying to be perfect in
protocol adherence and then it's
repeating data evidence protocol and do
it again and again and again
why are you vegan what's the thinking
behind that uh by choice so it blueprint
does not express opinions about anything
it doesn't say whether veganism is good
or bad or meat is good or bad it just is
a process to say measurement evidence
protocol and so I basically just asked
my team is it possible
for us to do a vegan protocol and be
within the targets of the optimal
clinical outcome ranges so the only
exception is I take collagen peptides
I'm trying to find a vegan source for
that but yeah it's a preference not a
necessity why do you prefer it
uh because I would like to
I hope
that a scale a scaling law of technology
that
the more
intelligent
a system gets
the more compassion that it has
so this is an ethical veganism substrate
a little Foundation that you're playing
on top of reducing animal suffering I'm
gonna guess
it it's a
it's a contemplation that
the the problem that Humanity the only
problem we have to solve as a species
really is goal alignment
we have these god-like Powers now
we just simply need to figure out not
simply we need to figure out how to
cooperate and that means not just humans
but humans and planet Earth and humans
and AI like trillions and trillions and
trillions of Agents of intelligence
whether they're cells or whether they're
Bots or whether it's plants or whatever
it is we have this gigantic tapestry of
computational goal alignment
and it's a problem of a size and scale
that just baffles the mind it so far
exceeds anything we're content we're
we're capable of and so when I think
about the real game we're playing here
at the largest possible scale of this
mathematical model
uh I hope that we Trend towards
compassion
because while we are alpha on this
planet right now that's not I don't
think we're Alpha anymore and I think
that we are going to want the attribute
of compassion to exist in this broad
tapestry of intelligence
would it potentially be
easier
simpler more efficient more effective
for you to add animal products in have
you ever considered trying to do that is
there a point in the future at which
you'll say let's do a six-month test
where
fish comes in or seafood comes in or or
red meat comes in yeah
I've shared everything I've shared the
entire blueprint protocol so people can
do it
and they can share their data I
personally don't want to do it
right I understand
in order to get the nutrients that you
need without touching on animal products
I imagine that that's a very large
amount of vegetables that you need to
eat
I mean I don't know large I mean the my
if you just look at the evidence and you
say my I'm trying to goal align 35
trillion cells
that make up me and the objective
function is to reduce entropy
so I'm I'm running this this massive
computational model with 35 trillion
cells on goal alignment with myself
and I'm basically saying can everything
inside of me try to go after one goal
Which is less entropy
and we're looking at all the evidence
we're looking at all the different data
but to me it's a really interesting
quandary because we think about goal
alignment and cooperation of can we get
AI to align with eight billion humans
can we get a hundred and you know 60
some odd nation states to cooperate on
planet Earth like we're always thinking
about these big cooperation problems but
the the cooperation problem the goal
alignment problem Almost Never
is asked of each one of us we get to
always Point our finger at everyone else
and blame everyone else and ask everyone
else to align their goals with ours
we're not being asked to do the tough
work to say hey you know what inside of
each of one of us is an absolute War
it's a balkanized war with our very with
our various selves and so to me the
Mastery of self is the ultimate
challenge for anyone to go after it's
harder than going to the moon it's
harder than going to Mars and that's I
think where if we're going to succeed as
a species that's the hard work we need
to do
we do not have complete control over
ourselves though right we don't even
know what ourselves are we are
self-deceptive we often have
contradictory and destructive behaviors
and desires that we want to engage in
and how do we know we don't we don't
have a metric that says I want it I want
a relationship but I also want to be
good at business but I also want status
but I also want to have fun with my
friends but I also want to sleep well
and I also want to be healthy you know
for us to be able to
pull all of these together yeah is
challenging and I want to get on to
self-destructive behaviors but before we
even get to that
how can someone work out what it is that
they want to want in life
so if uh
this is fun talking to you
um
this is the exact problem I've been
trying to solve and this is why I say
the mind is dead
so when I approach this problem with
myself the difficulty I had was
I myself was out of control I would
overeat
I would engage in all kinds of
self-destructive behaviors I was 50
pounds heavier than my healthy weight I
was marching myself into the grave
and I couldn't stop myself no matter
what
and so that was like the like the
personal problem I was trying to solve
which then Maps like some other
Ambitions I had
but when I look at myself
and I'm trying to distill those kinds of
questions like who am I what do I want
what are my goals
there's thousands of Brian's chiming in
like right now it's you know it's 10 30
a.m Brian speaking 5 30 PM is going to
have a different brains on every
different answer Saturday Brian's gonna
have a different answer with friends
Brian's gonna have different answers
like there's thousands of different ways
I'm going to answer it based upon my
biochemical State I trust none of them
and that's why you know I don't know how
to tackle this complexity so what I said
is like what is the most basic and
simplest possible thing I could do that
would actually wrestle my chaos into
some order and you know like
try to eliminate the unruliness of of my
existence and that's what blueprint has
done and that's why I follow the
algorithm it's it's freed me from this
Insanity which used to be me but you had
to make a value judgment at some point
right you had to say that the goal that
I'm going for isn't to maximize status
it's not even within the world of health
and fitness to maximize muscle mass to
compete in a bodybuilding show to
maximize my endurance or my HRV or my
VO2 max or whatever it might be
there was a point at which you had to go
through a process of stepping back and
saying what do I want to want
yeah that was the first step that had to
be the first step yeah yeah
foreign
step number one don't die
stay alive well that's the problem with
alignment right you know that's the
concern that everybody has as soon as
you get a self-aware recurrent
Improvement yeah AGI Okay so
um
Daniel Kahneman often talks about this
idea of um uh two uh levers that you can
use to encourage Behavior change one of
them being uh try harder and one of them
be sort of stop doing the things that
are stopping you from doing the thing
more so press on the accelerator further
or release the break and I think what I
like about your approach is that you
your first priority as far as I can see
is stopping pressing the brake before
starting to press the accelerator stop
doing the self-destructive Behavior what
is your framework for identifying
self-destructive behaviors and
overcoming them
it's a a complicated question and I've
tried to simplify the thinking of it
anything that increases my speed of
Aging
I label as self-destructive anything
that slows my speed of Aging is
rejuvenative
so try to just make it very clean left
or right
and what about overcoming it how do you
do that you've got the many Brians
coming in yeah and I you know I've heard
you talk previously about the fact that
it's not about what 5 p.m Brian wants to
do he's a dick it's it's what the plan
says that he's supposed to do and then
when 5 PM Brian comes around I have a
friend who uses uh the term I'm just
working for the boss so when it's his
time to do something to get up and start
writing a book or whatever it is that he
needs to do I'm just working for the
boss I don't make the decision the boss
already made the decision previously I'm
working for the boss the boss also
happens to be you but it's not as simple
as I have made a prescribed set of rules
that I'm supposed to follow therefore at
5 PM when my felt sense changes oh I
remember the protocol there's motivation
and and there's there's a felt sense of
what we're supposed to do so like take
me through or what are the lessons that
people can take away for improving that
adherence for not having to rely on
motivation as much for improving their
discipline if that's even what you refer
to it as yep
yeah I uh I'm currently putting together
a team of Behavioral change experts and
I wanted to do this as a public
experiment I'm going to invite
whoever wants to participate
in a 30-day challenge
to try to get their self aided
destruction scores to zero and so the
easy ones we target would be eating too
much food eating junk food skipping
exercise not meeting your bedtime like
just some really basic ones not get into
the nuanced ones where you know is
gaming good or bad under what
circumstances you know like let's leave
those complicated ones out just can you
stop the blatant self-aided destruction
behaviors and then to have five
behavioral change experts
represent you know present their school
of thought like here's our protocol
here's how you go about doing it CBT
versus whatever and then have people
choose the school of thought that they
resonate with and then just have the
teams compete for who can lower their
self you know their sad scores the most
so I'm in no way an expert in this area
on behavioral change and I just thought
it'd be a cool thing to try to
popularize sad that um
we've normalized sad in societies so
much so that you can do it out in the
open with friends and everyone's cool
with it no one calls it out and it's all
expected and if you don't participate in
sad you get called out and ostracized
from the group you're the one who's
meant to feel like you don't belong
and so for me personally it was uh a
food is a gateway for bad behavior for
me
and that was really where the dam was
breaking and so doing this protocol with
blueprint was a way to arrest the most
violent destructive behaviors I had and
then the other ones have just been baby
steps on top once I got control there uh
that kind of discipline has been
naturally extending everywhere else in
my life
but uh this is I guess this is why I get
excited about the future of being human
is if this algorithm legitimately can
arrest my worst uh proclivities that I'm
helpless to to get to arrest you know uh
cannot do other things for me too
including can I get into my mind one day
of stopping all the self-destructive
harm I do on my uh to myself with my my
own mind
and so this just takes a remapping of
what it means to be human
but I've never been happier and more
fulfilled and you know it's funny
because people
when they observe my behaviors their
assumption is that I'm sad
which is weird which is ironic meanwhile
you know they're drowning in their own
sad behaviors and I'm the one that
should be ostracized so it's a really
funny self-defense mechanism to try to
soothe oneself from what they're doing
what were the steps that you found most
effective at stopping yourself from
binge eating
it was uh separating myself into
multiple I'm not one person I am many
and then it was identifying the specific
most egregious version of myself which
was evening Brian he showed up at 7 pm
every night so I identified who he was I
gave him a name I listed out his
persuasion tactics like you know it's
been a long day you deserve it you did
really well at this you you worked out
really hard you probably already burned
the calories off tomorrow we start all
the persuasion tactics and then when he
shows up I
I treat him as other hybrid hi even
Brian I see you're here I see what
you're trying to do with your persuasion
techniques and you're not like you have
been unauthorized to make decisions on
how to you know you can't eat food like
period you have no authorization and so
it's like this this game of going about
doing it and in my mind when I do that I
can see evening Brian throw a tantrum
you know that the fact that his
authority has been revoked and how
offended he is and how outraged he is
and how he's just if he could be violent
he would be uh but it's just it's
phenomena that's psychologically so
interesting to watch How I myself play
Within Myself on these in these
dialogues and at first it was really uh
is contentious you know like you feel
that tension and you're so close to
breaking for him overpowering but it was
really uh personalizing these aspects of
myself and making them other and then I
could work on them one at a time
that's interesting so
othering yourself
creating a distance between you and the
things that you tell yourself
understanding that that
it is you but it's it's a malignant
version of you it's like an evil Alter
Ego or some conjoined twin that keeps on
coming in and talking to you about
things that you kind of
they're born out of your desires but
they're not your highest desires they're
not your truest desires they're not the
things that tomorrow you would have
wanted yourself to have done
yes
you're creating that distance I like
that I like anything that involves
having a mindfulness Gap you know a
break in between stimulus and response I
think more of that is very very good
what is it some insane number of our
decisions we've made the day before some
insane number of the thoughts that we
have today we had yesterday some insane
number of I mean here's a really really
great Insight from a friend Alex homozy
and he says that um
when people talk about changing their
diet to improve the things that they eat
they often get lost in the weeds around
conceptualizing what the diet consists
of but he said you probably eat
maybe eighty percent of your calories
from the same 10 meals
there are 10 meals that you have that
probably consist of like almost the
entire Lion's Share of your diet like
I'm not a chef I I have
maybe five good recipes in my back
pocket
okay so all that you actually need to do
is just change those things
right you're actually focusing on those
small number of decisions and it's kind
of the same with this so yeah I mean I I
think that for me I've realized the the
most self-destructive behaviors that I
have too is probably evening eating that
I've had this long day and I mean I live
in Austin Texas now and everybody goes
for barbecue everybody goes for
um whatever and they oh well there's
dessert and then there's home and then
there's snacks and then so on and you're
like it's 10 p.m and I stopped eating
half an hour ago yeah um so that's why
I'm particularly interested in in your
uh in your approach for it
yeah I mean it's it's hard to be human
and I think if if we are um
if we can all be honest just for a
minute
and
to to confess
that we are helplessly and hopelessly
engaged in self-destruction all the time
as a starting point
and not try to spin up uh these pretty
little stories about that's what it
means to live or this is what brings me
happiness
their lies
but we've done such a phenomenal job of
making them pretty stories and
protecting them because we don't want to
face this uncomfortable reality
but we are a species addicted to
self-destructive behavior and I don't
think this is the form of intelligence
that we want to be walking in as we
engineer AI
I think we know again we have this
tendency to point our finger at
everything in the world except for
ourselves
as the thing that needs to change
to play devil's advocate for the other
side I think that
much of the behavior that people do
could be classed as self-destructive
especially using the parameters that you
set out earlier on but people can't know
what they don't know
and for somebody who doesn't understand
that the behavior that there that
doesn't understand that binge eating
isn't actually good for them because it
helps them to relax for those people
we're getting into a philosophical sort
of linguistic lexical question here but
I don't know if it is quite the same
it's the Pandora's box or Plato's Cave
thing here right like if you don't know
that the thing that you're doing is
destructive is it fair to say that those
people have the same sort of obligation
to be aware of their self-destructive
Behavior you can't know what you don't
know hmm
talking about training that was one of
the other levers binge eating
skipping training sessions
what has the data said to you about the
optimal setup for a training protocol
for yourself what does it consist of how
often do you do it what time of the day
Etc
yeah I work out an hour a day at uh
cardi it's basically I try to flex and
stretch every muscle of my body
and we've worked back through the
science of what is cardio zones to be in
and we also look at this in terms of
measurements of my VO2 max of my
flexibility of my tendon ligament
strength of my we measure my muscle with
ultrasound we do whole whole body fat on
MRI so we're we're using these
quantitative endpoints we probably do a
hundred different markers that
quantifies my exercise protocol
and they're all markers that we can map
to Optimal clinical outcome ranges so
again the the goal I'm a problem I'm
working on is my 35 trillion cells
having less entropy so I'm not trying to
engage in a marathon I'm not trying to
right achieve some athletic uh record
and so really is that one goal and so um
yeah so it's just a bunch of Weights uh
cardio flexibility strength training
I noticed looking at your routine that
you've got a good bit of knees over toes
and Patrick's stuff in there
and that's been borne out in the data as
something which is very effective
yeah as we measure my my tendons and
ligaments uh specifically they've all
dramatically improved
and this is a good bit of backwards sled
drag some of the atg knees over toes
lungy stuff what were you most surprised
by uh what are the exercises or the
contributing routines that you do while
you're like [__] I wouldn't have thought
that that would have been in there I
wouldn't have thought that the data
would have been happy with me doing this
hmm
I suppose overall I'm surprised by
how robust I feel
I've actually never felt this robust in
my entire life even when I was 18 years
old and a an athlete in high school
and I don't have a single ache and pain
in my body I've never been more flexible
I've never had better cardiovascular
capacity
so I guess I'm just surprised that at
the chronological age of 45
I would be peaking in my life of ability
and I don't feel like I'm
entirely I mean I think there's more I
could gain
but I suppose I didn't I previously
viewed this as trying to stop an
inevitable downward Trend but it's
actually dramatically improved and
maintained
are you adding in walks each day on top
of this you know an hour a day for me if
I was to think about it doesn't seem
like much to optimize you know the
absolute optimal amount I would have
presumed it would have been two and a
half hours and it would have included
all manner of high intensity interval
training in a shitload of zone two and
then there would have been a 45 minutes
of Yin Yoga stretching with breakfast
you know what I mean I would have
thought it would have been more but why
isn't it more why aren't you training
more
uh
there's a
it's a It's Tricky puzzle we're trying
to solve I mean so we I'm on a caloric
restriction diet so it's 2 000 calories
and I take 100 pills a day and so the
scientific question we're trying to
solve is
if in the year 2023 someone like myself
wants to be an Explorer like Shackleton
or Magellan or Lewis and Clark and I
want to say all right I want to go to
the absolute limits of what's possible
in the form of slowing my speed of Aging
then we're trying to optimize for uh
caloric input uh cardiovascular activity
heart rate variability you know when you
do too much exercise there's a U-shaped
curve where you start inflicting harm on
the system and so you're trying to tune
all of these things with caloric
restriction it has a side effect of
lowering testosterone so I need to
supplement testosterone to get myself in
the normal levels and so we're just
playing this really tricky playoff
trade-off space all across the board and
we're always making Minor Adjustments
here and there trying to maximize for
this very narrow goal of slowing entropy
in my body interesting yeah because if
your RDA of of cows is what two six two
five
uh sorry what would be your recommended
oh yeah yeah yeah maintenance for you
would be two five or two six yeah two
six five five yep right okay and you're
a 1980 or something like that basically
two thousand uh if you were to train
more because that's not I mean you're
quite light right you're about 160
pounds I think yes yeah so you are quite
light
um but
still like maintenance at 2-6 given that
you train for an hour a day and it's not
like you're not doing other stuff
throughout the day too exactly isn't
isn't a massive amount so I understand
now if you were to really start to push
that if you go from UH 60 Minutes to 90
minutes to two hours your maintenance
cows then get up into the sort of 3000
range and then you go okay do we want to
be in a 1 000 calorie deficit every day
well no okay therefore we need to bump
calories up yeah what because G flux
Theory which you may or may not be
familiar with something we've spoken
about in the show before what's the
problem
with increasing your caloric output and
then increasing the amount of food you
could eat this means that you can eat
more food throughout the day this would
mean maybe you're more satiated there
will be a sweet spot how come you guys
haven't decided to do that yeah exactly
right uh really well said so we are
um
the combination we're doing is not
common so it's caloric restriction it's
intense exercise it's vegan
which a lot of people haven't really
combined robustly and we're trying to do
that all to maximize speed of Aging and
so we we have not covered all the
variations uh for example like I don't
know what my markers would be like with
meat I don't know what my markers would
be like with 90 more minutes of
cardiovascular exercise and more
calories so we haven't covered all the
iterations and the reason why I've been
trying to
uh share all my data is to say here's
the process we're going through to trial
the thing you can do this yourself and
you can do different iterations yourself
so add meat add more exercise do this or
that and then share your data too but
let's do that let's try to accelerate
the speed in which we can structurally
advance the field even if it's n of one
all right it's again better than n of
zero uh yeah but but
um the evidence of my that my teens
looked at uh they their current
hypothesis is what we're doing does
optimize and I guess there's some
interesting data where uh using DNA
methylation patterns looking at this the
Newton Pace algorithm over this
longitudinal study of nearly 2 000
people who have been measuring their
speed of Aging over uh several years
time I rank number one as the most
reduced speed of Aging out of the entire
group
and so it's interesting uh I hope others
take that spot from me that's the goal
hey what if somebody someone might come
in and and do that would you consider
switching protocols if somebody did do
that absolutely I mean that's the whole
goal right I mean I want someone to beat
me uh for that same purpose like build
the field and and share with everyone
what you're doing and so that's why I
share Freedom with every everyone what
I'm doing is I want them to do it and
then apply their own uh betterment and
everyone improves and so crowdsourcing
longevity research yeah and yeah it's
just like it's uh I mean the intensity
of competition which this has triggered
has been incredibly inspiring like I
mean people it's a big deal and so I I'm
in private conversation with a ton of
people about how they can beat me and I
I sincerely hope they do
what would your testosterone be at
without the supplementation have you got
any idea because you're walking around
at five percent body fat heavy caloric
restriction Etc
yeah I don't know uh we we hover around
800.
we hover around normal uh but that's
with um
uh I think it's nine units a day of
testosterone uh is that true it's 2mg
patch I think each one converts into
like nine something like that I forget
that's a dermal patch of testosterone
I've never heard of yeah that being a
delivery mechanism for testosterone
before is that common
uh it works yeah so I mean it keeps my
levels steady it's a dermal patch
yeah [__] yeah yeah I mean it's much
cooler than having to you know pin I am
every three days or whatever two and a
half times a week or something throw the
patch on go about your day peel a patch
off put the second one and go about your
day that's pretty cool yeah yeah
very interesting so
you mentioned there that we both
mentioned that you're running a um quite
low body fat percentage
why is that the optimal position for
somebody to be in you would have thought
well ancestrally the average body fat
for somebody that was moving around a
lot would have probably been
significantly higher uh how is it or
what's your thinking behind the fact
that in the fives range which is like
ridiculously lean
um
why do you think that that seems to be
optimal as opposed to having high level
of body fat
yeah I mean in questions like this I
would always defer to my team you know I
can I can Echo what I've heard them say
but I mean I I learned this as a pilot I
trained I got certified to fly in
several airplanes that got typed but I
had a rule for myself that I always flew
with someone else who was a professional
because when I was in the cockpit even
though I knew what I was doing I was
never as fluid and as competent as them
uh when they that's all they did every
day all day is thinking about that
versus me jumping in and out and so uh
and then also just knowing that if you
have five longevity experts doing this
doing this they're all going to disagree
but um yeah we've just been following
the evidence of you know caloric
restriction has some meaningful evidence
and like we're looking at these made
these lifespan of Health span studies
and we try to follow it and so I don't
know if uh five percent body fat is a
target of more of where the body has
settled out at it's a byproduct of the
fact that you're doing this caloric
restriction and that is why your
particular body ends up setting out
somebody else would be at three and a
half someone else would be at seven and
a half on the exact same protocol okay
interesting one of the things that I
haven't heard you talk about is heat and
cold exposure this is the current most
popular
um Bro Science approach for a longevity
routine are you using ice baths are you
using Sonar exposure do you consider it
a hormesis stressor have you tested with
it
we uh
we kind of don't do anything that's
popular right now
and we we've looked pretty carefully at
a cold and hot exposure we've looked at
Hyperbaric
and it's not to say that these things
don't have benefits it's that they don't
have benefit in the ways where we have
objectives
and so I mean there's an unlimited
number of things I can do in a given day
that would potentially be useful to me
but we have an extremely specific goal
of slowing my speed of Aging
and when you have that narrow of a goal
it just creates a really clean workspace
to say does this thing have inclusion or
does it not and so no we don't do any
colder or heat exposure
that's interesting I'm starting to kind
of get a conception about this this
singular ordinating principle slow down
the speed of Aging that means that there
are other things that other people who
have slightly different ordinating
principles might need to add in but
let's say that it was your goal to
optimize uh dopamine throughout the day
okay well you maybe you would look at
adding in cold exposure maybe you would
even look at adding in cold exposure
multiple times throughout the day and
maybe you would do some research to look
at whatever the equivalent of the
Circadian rhythm for dopamine is and
well maybe we can bring it up on flat
points and maybe we can boost it on
other points and maybe we'll be taking a
bunch of supplements and that would be
the ordinating principle if we want to
maximize dopamine throughout the day
it's interesting that um
slowing the speed of Aging
and you would have done it had it been
something that you think would have
contributed to it hasn't folded heat and
cold exposure in you said we're not
doing the things that other people are
doing but you're not doing them because
other people you're not not doing them
because other people do them you're not
doing them because presumably the data
doesn't suggest that it's something that
should be worthwhile yep again very well
said it's strange that it's not looking
at the data the data isn't screaming at
you get in a [__] cold tub or like
going a sauna like it's strange that
that's not happened I think
yeah yeah it's hard I I really
um we we get asked about I get asked
about cold exposure I think more than
anything and
um
my objective is not to rain on anyone's
parade it's not to discourage anyone
who's trying to do good for themselves
is not to try to be a know-it-all I've
just really not wanted to engage in the
conversation you know it's not part of
my protocol fine whatever you know like
I don't need to go out and trumpet it
and I don't want if other people are
excited about it that's wonderful but
really this is trying to move the entire
field forward and uh you know I think
there's a certain disposition that helps
people feel encouraged and so maybe
we'll find the evidence and maybe it'll
be uh something we do in the future like
I never know like I every time I've
expressed an opinion I've come back to
think I'm never expected an opinion
again except you just never know where
it's going to go but I will say that you
know with with what we're doing now with
sleep and diet and exercise
maybe it solves my dopamine for me I
don't know I mean I don't currently have
a dopamine problem I think you know like
my mood is never been more stable in my
entire life I've never felt more more
motivated in my entire life so it's just
different ways of saying it but I think
what you said really was a nice
construction where if you don't have the
clarification of endpoint
then it really gets in this fuzzy space
of where you don't really know where to
put that piece of the puzzle and then
people can misinterpret how to think
about it
I remember I heard stories about both
Elon Musk and Jeff Bezos and during his
time at Amazon Bezos had one ordinating
principle that every single decision
went through and it was does this
improve customer experience does this
improve customer experience every single
decision and musk's apparently may still
be was does this get us closer to Mars
every single thing every single question
does this get us close to Mars do I go
to the party this evening or do I go to
bed do I decide to hire this person or
do I satisfy this person do I decide to
start this new company or invest here or
buy Twitter or sell Twitter or tweet or
do whatever
does this gets us closer to Mars there's
maybe an argument to be made some of the
tweets that he's put out probably don't
get as closer to Mars but I I think
taught me the value of a single
ordinating principle Ryan holiday's book
from last year discipline is Destiny the
biggest takeaway that I took from that
conversation was that without a goal
without an ordinating principle there
can be no discipline before that because
the discipline is in service of the
outcome what are you being disciplined
for like what is discipline and given
the fact that we are these
multi-factorial multivariate creatures
with all conflicting goals and
self-deception and 5 p.m Brian and 7pm
Brian and tired Brian and hungry Brian
if you don't have a very very clear goal
it's almost impossible to be disciplined
in the service of it and
okay
in your opinion then
is it more difficult to live a life with
more than one goal or the more goals you
have does life become exponentially more
difficult working back on that yeah
after doing this for a while
this is why
I arrive at the mind is dead
so so if it's so let's just walk through
this the process like if I say an
algorithm
now takes care of me better than I can
myself with the goal of minimizing aging
so it's all it's a singular
objective
that simplifies all the decisions around
it
but what I'm really trying to
demonstrate is this is a system of goal
alignment so it doesn't matter what you
choose of your goal when you can take 35
trillion agents and goal align them
around a singular thing you've built a
tapestry of goal alignment
so blueprint can scale to anything
blueprint can scale to climate change
right the the Earth is the body you take
millions of measurements
you look at the evidence of what is a
proper biosphere for the coral reef and
the acidity in the oceans and all the
above
you apply a protocol and you repeat data
evidence protocol
the same is true for everything else and
what I'm really trying to say is if we
are thinking about the future of
existence
the problem we have to solve
is goal alignment and that we have to do
that so we don't destroy a biosphere we
have to do that so we don't have
dystopic outcomes with AI we have to do
that so we don't annihilate each other
because we're of our propensity towards
violence it is the singular goal we have
as a species and so I'm trying to prove
uh this this system with myself the one
thing I have control over
I would maybe be tempted when you say
the mind is dead
it's nice because it's like playing off
that God is dead thing
but you must have throughout your day
thoughts that you enjoy
creative insights that reflect on your
life introspection about memories dreams
and hopes for the future so there is
still a very real role for the mind it
seems it's a little bit more like
decision making is dead in that regard
um but yeah I think you've spoken a
couple of times about why your emotions
are at regulating emotions uh you even
said earlier on that spirituality or
like being spiritual is a component of
this fold in
your protocol for emotional health and
and spiritual health as well how does
that play a role how have you learned to
optimize that what are your Frameworks
and and uh perspectives on it yeah
you're right that the sitting beneath
the abstract layer of the mind is dead
there's all this Nuance of like even
when autopilot flies the airplane I'm
still Landing the airplane and taxi in
the airplane so my mind is still engaged
in some of these activities but the bulk
of the autopilot you know like it's nice
to know I've got that when I'm flying
and so but what it is really trying to
convey is the only tool we've ever had
in existence to manage ourselves is our
mind
and when I look at myself
my objective is to destroy my Nemesis
before my Nemesis destroys me and my
mind is my most powerful nemesis
and so as we as we start breaking out
the complexities the nuances of what
role do our minds have in society going
forward
and if we are trying to look at this
large computational problem of goal
alignment what is that role and to me
it's a legitimate question but the very
first thing that I can say confidently
about myself is who inflicts the most
self-destruction upon Me of anything in
existence
it's myself
if we say as we as a species who
inflicts more pain upon us than anything
else it's ourselves if I say
probabilistically who's a bigger worry
to me AI or humans humans like I'm
trying to get to the root of where is
the threat uh coming from
and what might we do to try to offset
that now what what spawns after that in
terms of what kind of spiritual
practices we have and how do we find
meaning those are all really cool and
fun questions we can play with on you
know once we have the free space to do
so but we're not in a safe safe place
right now as a species at all like we're
under extreme threat and so what I'm
really trying to do is address the the
things that are most pressing that
threaten our very existence and survival
so we can get to this play Space
what about when you face negative
unwanted emotions throughout the day
they're going to arise they're the sort
of things that you have significantly
less control over than what goes in your
mouth than how you train and then the
time that you go to sleep then the
temperature of your cooled and heated
mattress
um you know these are
unknown unknowns in some regards so how
have you learned to deal with emotional
regulation uh in an effective way and
what strategies can people take away
from that
I mean I I was chronically depressed for
a decade likely the result of being an
entrepreneur and working my talent off
building Braintree Van Well having three
little babies in a bad relationship you
know like all the stuff that you go
through hard hard times in life and so
if I look at that time and I look at the
Avalanche of negativity that buried me
every second of every day it absolutely
pinned me to the ground and I was
suffocating I couldn't breathe if I look
at now relatively speaking the amount of
negativity in my mind
there's like zero uh so getting these
basic things right in my mind in my in
my life like sleep and diet eliminating
these self-destruct behaviors I almost
rarely ever now have a genuinely
um
what would I call it a genuinely
self-destructive thought now I may
contemplate and say boy I wish I
wouldn't have said that thing or I wish
I would have said this thing differently
or I wasn't as nice as I wanted to be or
I feel a little ashamed about this kind
of thing like sure those are all little
mind you know we all do that with our
self-introspection to help us improve
but I would say generally speaking I've
eliminated the most hurtful and
self-destructive things that plagued me
to the point of suicide and uh I just
never thought that would be possible
Andrew hubman the first things that he
said on a podcast episode I did with him
was you do not control the mind with the
mind you control it with the body and it
seems to me like your mind is Downstream
from what you've been doing with your
body but I have a pet Obsession for
evolutionary psychology and it seems to
me that almost every animal humans
included aren't meant to be satisfied
with the inbuilt base programming
um outcome the the the the state that
humans are supposed to be in is minor
dissatisfaction does the um life is an
uh life is suffering from the Buddha
right the word for suffering is Duca
d-u-k-k-h-a I think and then some
Scholars contest that that word doesn't
mean suffering it means
unsatisfactoriness life is
unsatisfactoriness you know the holiday
that you plan to go on the stake that
you intended to eat there is always
something the sand between your toes it
could have been a tiny little bit more
salted it could have been a little bit
less well done
it it seems pleasantly surprising to me
that you as somebody that is trying to
optimize the body as much as possible
Downstream from that has found a very
large amount of peace
in the mind as well given what my
assumptions would have been about what
uh unperturbed human mentality would
have been
yeah I mean thinking about your frame if
if I were to try to oversimplify our
existence
you know see like we become conscious
and we become aware
that were in some sort of of uh
unpleasantness
hunger or you know need for status or
ambition like whatever but we just spend
our entire existence
trying to address our unpleasantness
that's it that's all we're doing and
then we make up all these stories and
games and the like the Buddha was saying
like hey like this is yeah this is this
is existence and the only way to deal
with existence is to eliminate this
permanently
but
to me that's really what we're we're
just walking around trying to deal with
our conscious selves and what I like
about where we're at as a species is
yes that's been the case but it may not
be the case if we have the the ability
in the form of computational
intelligence and we now can physically
predictably engineer atoms molecules and
organisms
we're in Uncharted Territory and this is
why I think the zero the future is like
a zeroth principle future we have no
ability whatsoever to model out what's
going to happen and that's never been
true with human society you know so
um sure that may be the state now we're
running from constant displeasure
but uh this is why I thought of this
computational goal alignment system
because it leads us to the future we
can't model out or predict and it may be
the most extraordinary thing humans have
ever experienced you know the
optionality is so vast that basically
any prediction goes out of the window
and the unknown and knowns start to get
exponential yeah Naval has a quote which
you'll be familiar with desire is a
contract you make with yourself to be
unhappy until you get what you want
given that you sold a company for 800
million dollars which has permitted you
aside from the conversation about you
need the physical resources monetary
time Etc to be able to focus on what it
is that you're doing
Naval also has a
um
really great Insight which is
it is far easier to achieve our material
desires than to renounce them and what
you're talking about previously is
um
the unsatisfactoriness the inherent
unsatisfactoriness or displeasure that
people feel on a daily basis is
something that you have largely been
able to dispense with
if you hadn't had such success
monetarily you know achieving the status
that you needed
do you think that open loop would be
intruding still on your life even if
let's say somehow you you managed to
have the uh someone else was paying for
all of these things to be done for you
right so like you know you materially
were able to make it happen
um
would that open loop do you think
I haven't achieved the ridiculous
success within business would that still
perturb your thoughts is that a loop
that needed closing
yeah so this is
this is a question
which my brain just registered as I just
I just uh flagged a few alerts in my
brain when you ask me this question
because it said to me
um hey this person's asking you your
opinion you're on uh basically there's
no data involved there's no reference
set there's no evidence just your free
from free form freestyle opinion
terrifying dangerous because I can
verify any [__] answer my brain comes
up with it's like but you know what it's
all [__] so like whatever words come
out of my mouth
are absolutely fabricated have zero
basis in reality and are a disservice to
everyone including myself
interesting so do you
let's say that you want to play around
with ideas you're at dinner or at the
first supper and somebody asks you a
question that you don't have an answer
for
how do you venture into the realm of
things that you don't know if you're
never prepared to venture into the realm
of things that you don't know
this is uh this is one of the thought
experiments I do at my dinners my the
blueprint brunches so I say okay let's
let's do a thought experiment where the
social Gathering we're playfully having
conversation I turned to someone and I
say hey I'm interested in hydration I
want to be better hydrated how much
water should I drink and so volunteer
will be like you know I'll play along
with you and typically they'll say well
I think it's like you know roughly eight
ounces or eight cups of water a day I
have this flask it's pink I take it with
me everywhere I go I'm always in the
bathroom it's kind of annoying my friend
Susie she has one too her mom thinks
it's really weird she carries it with
her her mom's kind of not doing very
well she's sick she has this other
friend who flew in from La the weekend
they're having dinner and they go on
thing right and then they finally come
back and they're like okay so yeah and
so I say okay great so your answer is
like eight eight cups of water a day yes
and then I do the thought experiment
again and I say how much water should I
drink and if they're paying attention
so I'm sorry I'm sorry at the end of the
previous discussion I say how do you
know eight cups of water a day and they
say well I read it somewhere like on
some website or you know something like
well have you seen the data do you know
no but I have seen it somewhere okay so
do the thought experiment again how do
you you know how much water should I
drink and if they're paying attention
the person says I don't know
if not they'll do the eight cups of
water but it really is meant to
demonstrate the majority of our social
interactions
serve the function of social cohesion
not truth seeking and as a result we
pass on these this lore which is not
true but we can't distinguish between
the social cohesion dance and what we're
passing on is knowledge
and so it's this clear distinction to
try to to discern
and so if you're really in a
truth-seeking discussion great like have
that but if you're in a social soothing
situation don't mistake the two because
it really
compromises everyone's shared ability to
understand reality and make good
decisions you muddy the sense making
landscape with people doing performative
conversation masquerading as truth
seeking foreign
that's really really interesting
um in your opinion then should nobody
speak on things that they don't have
data for and what is the role of playing
with ideas that are more difficult to be
analytical with
uh
I suppose it it depends on who the
conversations with
and what the objectives are
um you know if you're just there to have
fun if you're actually trying to solve a
problem uh you know these blueprint
branches I put I bring people together
and no one knows each other so it's it's
a set of accomplished people
entrepreneurs scientists engineers
astronauts Educators so everyone's kind
of doing the dance of filling each other
out they're trying to figure out ranking
and priority and Status they're trying
to like do all the social stuff and so
people are playing those different games
yeah I just say that my personal
participation
varies according to the group I'm in and
what we're trying to achieve
interesting
um one of the other things that you've
looked at and that you're optimizing is
a youthfulness on the outside not just
on the inside the way that you look
what is your perspective on sunlight
exposure onto the skin also onto the
face not just from a youthful
perspective but also from a health and
Physiology perspective
I don't know
I'll tell you that I typically avoid the
sun because my skin is almost always
healing from some kind of laser you can
see here on the screen see how these
dots all over my neck what's that from
laser so my I had we just we just bought
another laser and my face is still
healing from this
uh so my I'm my skin is sensitive to the
sun because it's in these healing
conditions so generally speaking I'm
always aware of the UV index when I go
outside I do wear sunscreen and we
measure my skin Health uh robustly we
use multi-spectral Imaging where it
looks at UV and red and Browns and pore
size we use autofluorescence we use mer
scores we do biopsies so we're looking
quantitatively at the skin from every
angle so that we can say with some
degree of confidence how my skin
protocol is doing with all the
treatments we're doing
uh but yeah uh generally speaking as I
understand it UV exposure has negative
effects on the skin of a certain type
with a certain duration with a certain
you know exposure array so just
generally I don't get a lot of sun
exposure are you aware of the brand of
sunscreen that you've ended up zeroing
in on presumably it's very well
researched with a bunch of chemicals
that aren't going to make you die sooner
yeah we use CeraVe am which is a 35 UVA
UVB and then also elta MD which is also
UVA eamb okay are they regularly
available or is this some Vietnamese
Pharmacy website
yeah yeah regularly oh cool okay that's
good
um yeah
yeah it's again I think that it's very
interesting to see what what's showing
up in the data uh you know a ton of my
friends very very big into earthing into
spending time outside in nature
rejuvenative practices and a big chunk
of that involves sunlight exposure yeah
a a non-insignificant cohort of them are
ones that have massive problems with
putting sunscreen on their body on their
skin because of what's going to happen
dermily is it going to get absorbed and
cause me to full of estrogens
um
I think that stress testing a lot of
these assumptions as you are doing is
very interesting I think that it's
helping to um
see where the rubber meets the road
yeah I mean to your point is it is funny
every time I say anything about anything
I get these predictable responses but
what about
cold exposure heat exposure
sun exposure you know uh oh wow I've hit
this basic [__] questions
was I you know did I get uh my bare skin
exposed to the grass exposure did I like
everyone has their frame of you know or
have I practiced some Eastern
you know meditative blank everyone comes
to me with their thing of like but what
about
and I I don't know what to say like we
haven't tested every permeation that's
ever existed we've run we've looked at
the data we look at the evidence we do
the thing and we report back
but that's it uh but but it is so
predictable and it's so funny that I put
something out and I tried like provide
something of useful Insight but then
people you know their question to
smother it into like it's not viable to
them at all because all these are the
variables compounded which I understand
I mean but it is funny that sometimes it
feels like it's one step forward and
four steps back when people parse these
things through all their filters yeah
you should have a page on your website
of uh like fsrs frequently stated
rebuttals and just what about cold
exposure I uh it it does not seem that
we have any added evidence to say that
we're going to introduce it what about
heat exposure it does not seem that we
have any of it what about sunlight
uh that would be maybe time saving one
of the things to consider you mentioned
that you're 45 you mentioned that you'd
spent you know a decade of your life
very aggressively building a company
during that time you were aging it
significantly probably quicker than your
biological age was
does that mean uh from an internal body
clock
perspective that
up until somebody really starts to take
this stuff seriously or or happens upon
it just by chance because they end up
having a really perfect lifestyle
naturally you're always going to be
running ahead of your of your current
age therefore is there a part of you
that regrets the fact that you didn't do
this 20 years ago
yeah
uh entirely
yeah I
uh my parents didn't know any better
because they were following social norms
but I ate sugar cereal for breakfast
sodas I was in the sun constantly with
no sunscreen
I mean I shot guns with no ear
protection you know I mean I just did
everything
um I could have done that would hurt my
health I did
and aggressively like I you know I was
like I'm full of life and
um I certainly had a lot of fun I'm sure
also it's very hard to correct damage
that has happened so with my children
for example my 17 year old who is with
me right now
he's almost entirely on blueprint and
you know
he to his credit
he fully realizes and he's so grateful
for starting this at his age
and so I mean it's exciting for him you
know at this age to be on this protocol
and while I mean his friends at school
they
he just got accepted to a prestigious
Institution for college he went there
before listen yeah I mean he did a
wonderful job I mean he worked as Talent
off in school and um
he went to this orientation and he sent
me this video and here are like some of
the most talented humans on planet Earth
and they're Downing sugar junk food
drinking not sleeping and I was like oh
my God this is just I'm so sad this is
the future of humans and like we've
normalized these behaviors so much and
they're sitting within this edifice of
intellectual aspiration doing these
things and I thought what a disconnect
between uh what we're trying to birth
intellectually and what they're doing
physically and I I'm glad that he had
the wherewithal to be like you know Dad
I'm glad I'm not doing these things I
know how badly uh poor sleep affects my
cognition I know how badly junk food you
know affects my my mood so
but I don't know it's been on my mind
ever since I haven't been able to stop
thinking about it
there are trade-offs though you know
there will be a time where your son
needs to pull an all-nighter before some
sort of project gets put in like we
inevitably given the fact that not he
right now doesn't just have live as long
as possible or reduce the speed of Aging
sorry as his single ordinating principle
it's also don't flunk University you
know it's also probably
um make my time at University
sufficiently enjoyable that I have
memories that I am fond of when I look
back it's maybe get a get a girlfriend
it's maybe play a sport it's maybe do a
bunch of other things so again we've
mentioned this earlier on the single
ordinating principle is great because it
creates a very easy filter through which
every decision needs to be made
there will end up being compromises that
will need to be made during everybody's
life right even during yours at some
point you will have an opportunity which
is so good that you think this is for
the greater good of blueprint but it is
going to mean that for this next week of
traveling and blah blah or I am actually
going to speed up my aging so and so
forth
the difference is
there are there is much lower hanging
fruit that some of his peers could pick
up on like maybe put the full fat Dr
Pepper down like maybe Domino's isn't
the best way to fuel yourself the night
before an exam etc etc
um
but I think that that displays quite
nicely the
level of or lack of wisdom around what
actually makes people
operate effectively
I mean if we I I understand practically
what you're saying
right the trade-off space you've
represented
um
what I would think would be worthwhile
for us to think about is
you just pulled out of your pocket
all of the favorite things we humans
like to pull out of our pockets
like create enduring Memories We want
this experience you know like we're
justifying the trade-off space and in
the in doing that what we're saying is
um
we always have the override switch to do
this at all times
and what I want to pose is and this is
how we currently think about ourselves
as a species
when we walk into this future
we bring those assumptions that
remain hidden to our own awareness
and so I like working with this concept
of of gen zero of this idea that we like
a group of humans
walking into the future that is willing
to divorce themselves from all human
norms and customs
because if you look at this and you say
okay how powerful is artificial
intelligence how fast is it going to
move and what is our relationship in
power going to be in relation to this
thing
we don't know and so I I understand what
you're saying on the trade-offs but it
comes with a question from this position
of luxury that we can always choose
under any circumstance and make those
trade-offs
and I want to say I'm open-minded
to the future of our existence may be
more wild and weird and different than
we can ever contemplate and if you again
if you just look at the mathematical if
you look at the curves of improvement
I think we're closer to that situation
than we realize
and this is what I'm really trying to
get across with blueprint is it is the
mind really dead like are we genuinely
in a situation where algorithms better
care for us and we're no longer pulling
the funny business of like oh well
here's a cool story I'm going to deviate
from now with it because of it
um and you know this just generates like
violent responses inside of people
because it steps on their sacredness
but I think this is a relevant
conversation for us to have
I think it's I think that you're right I
understand the point that you mean I
think what
what it does presuppose is that
axiomatically everybody else's
single ordinating principle would also
be slow down aging as much as possible
there are people out there for whom they
would say I have taken it from first
principles that say that they have all
of the Insight that you do and more and
they say my life wants to be something
which is not that my goal is to see as
many different countries on the planet
as possible I don't care about how long
I live or maybe I do care but it's third
thing down the list yeah as soon as you
fold that in as soon as you fold in any
other goal this is when the trade-offs
come and I understand that as soon as
you say there is uh there are trade-offs
that need to be made you open the door
to the executive function of you making
a decision not being outsourced to the
blueprint or the boss that made the
choice I understand that that's a very
dangerous game to play and I I from your
perspective and with your goals at the
moment I think it makes complete sense
but that does presuppose that everybody
else's goal also should be to live as
long as soon as you open the door to
that not being the case I think that the
trade-offs has to come in
yeah well so it's not even I'm not even
presupposing that everyone needs to have
my goal I'm saying that if you look at
the
the drivers of our existence where
artificial intelligence is a force that
needs to be reconciled with
that our biosphere and planet earth
needs to be sustainable and that needs
to be negotiated with and that we humans
need to not kill each other that needs
to be negotiated with so what I'm saying
is we currently do this in society like
we say you can't kill someone that's
against the rules you can't run someone
over with your car that's against the
rules like we do this in many ways today
we're already doing this massive goal
alignment thing in society is just going
to get much more computational in nature
because right now we see that when
humans do whatever they want whenever
they want it has negative effects on the
biosphere that make it unsustainable so
one of those things has to give either
the biosphere has to give and become
sustainable by itself or humans have to
be negotiated with on what their
behaviors are allowed to do
and this is what I'm saying you look at
the large-scale goal alignment problem
the presumption that we all have this we
can do whatever we want whenever we want
however we want may not be true it's a
different set of of considerations we're
walking into and so I bring up this is
really not to predict the future but as
a thought experiment to say if we are
serious about creating a future that
we're going to enjoy
I would much rather have an honest
conversation about the potential things
we need to be thinking about and the
changes in our life because everything
that you know Society is so delicately
balanced where we don't ask anything of
the individual it's always blaming
someone else and expecting someone else
to change we're never pointing itself
it's only the presumption is always I
can do whatever I want because it's me
but again I think we need to call into
question all these primary assumptions
Brian Johnson ladies and gentlemen if
people want to keep up to date with all
of the stuff that you do where should
they go
uh Instagram and Twitter
I love it man dude I find you very very
interesting very very enjoy this uh
very much enjoyed this kind of a
conversation one that ranges from
principles to philosophy to enacting uh
strategies as well is very very cool I
appreciate the stuff that you do
yeah I really enjoyed the conversation
thank you for having me on what's
Happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace